the secret sauce of amazon where there
are several principles at amazon but the
number one thing that has made us
successful by far
is obsessive compulsive focus on the
customer as opposed to
obsession over the competitor and i talk
so often to
other ceos
and
some other cos and also
founders and entrepreneurs
and i can tell that even though they're
talking about customers they're really
focusing on competitors and it is a huge
advantage to any company if you can stay
focused on your customer instead of your
competitor so then you have to identify
who is your customer
um so at the washington post for example
is the customer the people who buy
advertisements from us no the customer
is the reader
full stop the customer is the reader and
then
by the way
where do advertisers want to be
advertisers want to be where there are
readers so it's really not that
complicated you know it's sort of it
comes around really well and in the
school who are the customers is it the
parents
is it the teachers no
it is the child and that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna be obsessively
compulsively focused on the child we're
going to be scientific when we can be
and we're going to use heart and
intuition when we when we need to hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how you can
guarantee success for your life
enjoy
rule number two invest in yourself first
with warren buffett by far the best
investment you can make is in yourself i
mean that for example communication
skills i tell the students that come
that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas all that if they
just learn to communicate better and
both in writing and in person they
increase their value at least 50 percent
no i mean
if you can't communicate somebody says
you know it's like winking at a girl in
the dark nothing happens you know
basically and and you have to be able to
get
get both your ideas and uh
and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course some
people wish i take it a shorter course
now in terms of my talking later on but
it
it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself nobody can take
it away from you rule number three get
attention with grant cardone you better
get excited now because if you're not
gonna get excited now nobody will give
you this money
nobody will give you this money money
follows attention how much attention can
i get in the marketplace is where money
goes money does not go to the best
product ever
money does not go to the best product
money does not go to the happiest place
either money goes to where attention
goes whoever gets the most attention
gets the most money action massive
action has always worked it's proven
itself for thousands of years this is
not a new concept
you show me somebody and we know their
name anybody anybody in the in the room
any famous person
that you can think of
anybody that we would both know you say
i'm going to mention their name and
grant will know who that is
give me a name of one person
massive action
persistent massive action
okay
okay how many people were watching the
open yesterday
yeah exactly why
because tiger was in it
attention money follows attention
money follows attention how much
attention can you get even bad attention
okay i'm gonna tell you something
what tiger went through in the last
decade helped him
you got more white people pulling for
tiger woods
right they're like tiger grown white men
tiger and we say there's division in
this country tiger i love tiger
right why because they love a comeback
man the guy got a lot of attention
okay who else give me another name
oh my god i didn't i didn't know it's
gonna be this kind of
meeting if i didn't know there's gonna
be this kind of me i'd charge a double
donald trump donald trump
everybody knows it okay money follows
attention success and power follow
attention okay you cannot like the guy
but could you handle
that much heat
every day
could you handle that many people not
liking you every day
because if you're going to be a leader
if you're going to be a real leader okay
if you're going to be at the top of the
food chain kind of leader people aren't
going to like you also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four focus on
positivity with peter diamandis in that
same year i was the closing speaker uh
for president clinton at cgi
and at the end of his introduction he
said to me peter
why are you so positive about the future
don't you watch the news
and i said president clinton with all
due respect no i don't watch the news
and i look at the data
and so the reality is that as we humans
were evolving on the savannahs of africa
hundreds of thousands millions of years
ago back then if we missed a piece of
negative news like so rustling in the
leaves
is the wind and not a lion
you know the negative news could put you
out of your misery
and we developed an ancient piece for
our temporal lobe called the amygdala
about the size of your thumb that scans
everything you see in everything you
hear for negative news and if you see it
it puts you on red alert
and it's not something we control it's
something deep wired into our brains
and at the end of the day the news media
uses this
right the old adage if it bleeds it
leads is so true right if you ask
yourself the question you know what's
the news media's job
it's deliver your eyeballs to their
advertisers that's it pure and simple
and so if we're paying 10 times more
attention to negative news and positive
news open up the newspaper tomorrow
morning and just count the number of
negative stories to positive stories
it's extraordinary it's ten to one i
mean do the experiment
and it's not that they're you know
masochistic or that they want to just
you know have a negative mindset
it's their business
they don't show you all the other
amazing news going on in the world every
single day and so i choose not to watch
the news
i mean period i get back two hours a day
it's amazing my social network will tell
me what i need to know my family will my
friends will there's nothing i don't
miss i have google alerts for my
companies and the things that i care
about but allowing you know the crisis
news network or fox or whomever it might
be
to tell me what they think i should be
learning uh-uh not what i want to do
with my time rule number five be
prepared to walk alone with vuci
timberquayo i grew up
i grew up without
i suffered
i was told i'm worthless
now that i have it i'm going to show
everybody
because if they affirm to me that i am
then i must be
and it's not until you get to a stage
where you realize the affirmation is not
necessary that you're truly free
so as you build your business i'm
telling you now that if it's the
external affirmation you're looking for
you're gonna sickle
you're not gonna get it guys
it's hard like and it's it's not unless
you walk the journey right it's when you
are in it
that you're like why don't they get it
yeah the world must be they're losing
their minds
have you ever seen something that nobody
else sees but you know it's there
because you can see it you're like nah
and you explain it but they don't see it
right
and in that the only thing that keeps
you sane is if the only affirmation you
need is you
so it's kind of counterintuitive right
quickly before we start i gotta tell you
this i'll tell you why it's
counterintuitive
um
anthropologists and human science
specialists both have studied prisons
prisons are a fascinating thing right
because when you're a human being what
we do in this thing called a society
very careful of society by the way
because society is nothing more than a
system of normalized averages
so
so so what it is is
we all come together and we go well for
us for there to be order
in any system that can grow
exponentially ergo population growth we
need a system to manage it and we're
going to codify the system and we're
going to call these things
good behavior
etiquette
rules laws
if you break them we're going to punish
you
we have to do it otherwise there'll be
disorder like if nobody tells you sit on
the right hand side of the car and drive
on the left-hand side of the road you're
going to sit wherever you want you're
going to drive however you want
and we can't create a society like that
so what society does it writes these
rules it codifies them that create the
average for the average
the average human being should be like
this
that's why your mom says go to school
get a good education get a job
get a husband have two and a half kids
live in the white house with a picket
fence
that's why you're told that because your
mother comes from a society with a
system of normalized averages
and then you come up and go no maybe not
maybe i don't want to finish school or
maybe i do but i actually don't want to
get a job i actually want to go through
five years of not knowing where my next
meet is going to come from because i've
got a dream
the minute you break away from society's
rules it will do exactly what they do to
you in prison so check this out so you
break the law they send you to prison
why
because if we can remove you from
broader society we punish you
yeah
human beings by the very nature
need interaction
this is a vital part of being a human
being
when you're in prison and you break the
rules what do they do then
they put you in isolation
so just to be clear
to the strongest
toughest
most evil people of society
the single most powerful form of
punishing them
is separation
it's not physical punishment
i'm going to put you in a hole
alone
that's it
and it
will
break you
[Music]
that's why people don't have the courage
to walk the path of entrepreneurship
because the minute you're walking you're
going holy
i'm alone rule number six pursue
continuous growth with robin sharma i
believe your happiest not when you're
watching tv you're not happiest when
you're playing with your apps you're not
happiest when you're looking for likes
you're not happiest when you're fooling
around
you're happiest when you're growing
i think we're hardwired that it's a
survival mechanism
we're happiest when we're making
progress so we have a deep fear of
self-betrayal and when we when we don't
capitalize on our talents
what starts to happen
is that what starts to happen is that
we start to lose energy we lose
creativity and we lose productivity i
believe that many of us the reason we
don't have energy the reason why we're
not as creative as we want the reason
why we're not as productive as we want
is because we have betrayed our talent
and the deep wise primal hero within
knows of that self betrayal
and we start to hate ourselves is that
interesting point show of hands
the place of knowing within you knows
that you've betrayed your talents
and we start to hate ourselves
and so we have a deep well of
self-loathing inside of us that actually
minimizes the four interior empires and
the four interior empires are the
gateway into the exterior empires of
creativity productivity performance
prosperity lifestyle and impact how do
you get to creativity
productivity
prosperity
performance
lifestyle and impact
through the four interior empires
mindset heart set health set and soul
set
so that first fear is important
second fear fear of standing out well
how are you going to innovate if you
haven't worked through your fear this is
why personal mastery is the gateway into
it's the gateway it's the gateway drug
in the world class and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is don't work for the money
with robert kiyosaki the irony is you
know when i when i left school in the
60s there was plenty of jobs
but the world has changed
and our schools haven't
and so they're still making this innate
promise of get a job
and i was very fortunate when i
graduated in 69 we're the highest paid
graduates in the world my classmates
were making about 120 150 000 a year
there's not much money today
but 1969 that was a lot of money
but naturally as young guys do we spent
every penny of it
yeah
so i had my rich dad's lesson the rich
don't work for money in my head i said
okay
i'm making all this money i have a
secure job
but what's beyond that and that's where
education comes in
so if i could explain this to you for
the for the rest of the millennial
lessons it's really going to be on this
theme here
because financial education is about not
working for money
like one of the first questions when i
finally realized what my rich dad was
saying
i said well when do i never need a
paycheck again
see my goal wasn't you know
go to the moon or you know cure cancer
my job was when
would i never need a paycheck again
because as long as you need a paycheck
be it from an employer or like my poor
dad
he was so afraid of losing his
government pension yeah
and i'm going jesus what a way to run
your life your pension
so my old man kind of kind of got fired
he lost his pension
it was the most frightening thing in the
world to him he had no pension then it
was social security which is even worse
so that's why my goal when i was about
your age a little older around 25 i said
my goal is to never need a paycheck
again from anybody
even the government i don't want any
medicare social security
or whatever you know well as a military
pilot so you got to get the military
pilot pension i said you do but i'm not
going to
and just because of this here that was
the difference because i never wanted to
work for money to need a paycheck
so the next few lessons and millennial
money you'll find out what i do work for
so for right now just let me go to the
um lesson here
[Applause]
so this comes from rich dad poor dad and
this these are some other distinctions
it was the advantage i had at age nine
because i knew
what i wanted to work for
and this here in simple terms is called
a financial statement in school the
teacher get a fico score
fico is bs
all that means how good are you paying
your bills that's all fico means okay
should be the fido score good dog
so this is what your banker wants to see
so when i was
nine years old playing monopoly with my
rich dad this is the lesson that's not
included in monopoly but rich dad taught
me
and
fundamentally
the problem
that most people make they go to school
to get a job
and they work here so this is the poor
middle class in these guys
and we're going to talk about later your
first line item expense is taxes
you know just recently president trump
said he had a tax cut
he didn't have a tax cut for these guys
as you know the rules are always written
for the rich okay
i didn't make the rules you can get
angry at me but these are the rules the
rich make the rules the golden rule who
he who has a gold
makes the rules
yeah so the tax cut went to people here
that's where it goes you'll learn more
about this later on
but this is what i work for
so what i work for number one is
i'm an entrepreneur i want businesses i
have multiple businesses
and i don't work in them as you know
because you work here you never see me
do it no
because i don't work for a paycheck
exactly
next is real estate
and real estate is good
for many things which we'll go into but
number one is debt i use a lot of debt
to buy real estate and i pay no taxes
that's the relationship there the next
is paper
and that's saving stocks bonds mutual
funds etfs and that stuff i don't have
any of that stuff i don't save money i
don't any of that
but this is why most people have a go to
school get a job
get a 401k and save money
loser
i'm doing that just to upset you guys
because maybe you'll start to think
because i didn't make the rules i'm just
telling these the rules
these people pay the highest taxes
and they work the hardest
and the last are commodities
four different asset classes so
commodities are
number one is gold
silver oil
land water food
so this is what i work for when i left
school rather than working for a
paycheck
and working for money
my education had to go beyond getting a
job which i had a good job
but i now had to start when i left
school about your age
the thing i focused on first actually
was
commodities so back in 1972 i started
buying gold
and it was illegal for americans to own
gold you can imagine that
back in 72.
today you have bitcoin it's different
okay everything is changing so rapidly
today
so i started with gold
but actually the next thing was actually
oil because i went to school to be a
tanker officer driving ships for
standard oil
so i understand oil so i own my wife and
i don't own standard oil or chevron or
exxon we own oil wells again
taxes you get no tax breaks for owning
paper oil
huge tax breaks for owning real oil
and then i went into real estate
why because i can use debt to buy real
estate and because i use debt
i pay no taxes
and then third i started my business my
first real real business had many many
businesses as a kid
but my first real business was a nylon
and velcro surface wallet business
and i went worldwide right away the
trouble is i was an idiot
and the business went up
and the business came down
what kept me alive was this and this
okay
so you may say well aren't you working
for money but we'll go into that next i
don't want what's called
a paycheck
i want cash flow
from here
so that's what i mean by the rich don't
work for money
you want cash flow that pays very little
taxes
and i can use lots of debt over here the
average person went to school their
biggest liability they have is student
loans of course
yeah of course definitely
i mean it's horrible what they do to you
guys today
yeah student loan was just the worst
type of debt of all because you cannot
declare bankruptcy on it then you get
out you try and buy a house and you call
it an asset when it's really a liability
why because the cash is flowing that way
your house costs you money every you
rent a house still cost you money
okay then you have to have a nice car
i had one of those
so the problem with most young people is
they go to school to get that job
then a lot of it has student loan debt
then they try and get married and buy a
house they have a car
and then they have credit card debt
but they never have the chance to come
over here if they do any investing in
america it's a 401k
which i wouldn't touch with a 10 foot
pole now you should but i don't because
i don't have to
because i went to school for here
and people who don't go to school should
be here this is a 401k ira
etfs and that stuff paper
savings i don't touch that stuff and
we'll go into that later on okay
so when i say rich don't work for money
i never want to be dependent on a
paycheck either from an employer
or the government i want to be a free
human being
practice gives you ultimate freedom the
more you practice the better you get at
something the more skilled you are at it
the more information you have the more
it actually allows you to play more have
more fun be more flexible and have
ultimately more freedom this is
something i struggled with a lot in the
early days of my speaking career
i was asked to speak at a bunch of
events and
this is what 20 years ago i guess i've
had i've had as a speaking career now
and
i used to be so worried about
disappointing people that i would
memorize my entire speech i would
practice and practice and practice and
practice and practice and just memorize
my speech to the point where
word for word it would be the exact same
thing every time
and i thought that was good i thought
that's what you're supposed to do
obviously yes practice makes perfect
keep going keep practicing keep doing it
and
what ended up happening was yes i
delivered the same speech each time but
i think the worst thing you can do as a
speaker is just give the exact same
speech every time
we did a session of movement makers
around signature talk it was one of the
most voted topics was how do i give my
signature talk and i think having one
signature talk is actually not great i
think you should be able to
be able to speak to the audience every
time your job if you're a speaker is to
give your audience a fantastic
experience and so it's knowing who's in
the audience don't assume it's the same
people every single time
right so you have to be able to know so
much about your subject that then you
can have your framework that you operate
in but then
give a lot more
value to people by making accustomed to
them
so now whenever i'm doing a speaking gig
i'm always asking okay tell me about the
audience tell me who's here tell me why
people are setting up what are people
here for both in terms of the
information they're hoping to get
as well as their background and their
interests and their concerns and what
they struggle with and of course there's
genuine human struggles that everybody
goes through but why are people here at
this conference
and so here's my process right now when
i'm doing
a a speech or talk
they're going to have me come in they're
going to talk about believe or
entrepreneurship or youtube there's
going to be some set themes you're not
having me come to talk about my apple
strudel recipe
because i don't have one right i'm
coming in and talking about things that
are inside my domain perfect
and i can easily just get up on stage
and talk
but i want to know who's in the audience
so
before going i'll ask them tell me about
the people who are going to be here
and then i'll frame my speech around a
couple of key ideas that
i think would be valuable to that
audience still sitting within kind of
the my usual domain perfect
i'll practice it
i'll practice giving a speech i'll
practice the points
at home i'll practice i'll practice
talking to my dog i'll practice on the
airplane on the way over i'll practice
to kind of get a sense of the stories
that i want to tell that i think will be
the right fit
but then the day before and the day of i
like to be there little early to to talk
to people to
one makes me feel a little more
comfortable um
be able to connect to people in the
audience so it's not just
people i don't know but i've had a few
conversations with people but two
in
feeling the vibe out of the event
i'll often end up switching up part of
my talk
again to make it as customizable as
possible to the people i'm talking to
and this isn't just a speaking thing
guys this is any interaction you're
doing you're trying to sell your product
trying to sell your service you're on a
call with somebody who could use your
product or service hire you as a coach
etc you have to customize your pitch
customize your talk for them not just
give the same thing every single time
you're talking to somebody you have to
know what makes them tick know why
they're talking to you what their their
deep desires and fears are and address
those things so that you can
close the sale right it's the same thing
i'm just giving an an example through
speaking
so it's being willing to deviate
from your talk
to actually give more value
and i think again the worst thing you
can do as a speaker is just give get on
say you can get the same talk every
single time
that's what i used to think was the way
to go but this is actually a lot more
valuable
because you can inspire people but one
it becomes boring for you to get up and
just do the same thing over and over and
over again and two if you can customize
it to actually address the thing that
they're specifically concerned about
you're gonna have a bigger impact why
are you there you're there to touch
people you're there to move people to a
positive direction right
again whether whether you're speaking or
you're just talking to somebody on the
phone a potential client why are you
working with them yes they're going to
pay you but why you want them to get a
result you want them to move you want
them to make a change you want to solve
a problem for them and so the more you
can actually connect to what they're
struggling with the easier it is for you
to to close the sale and have the impact
that you're trying to have so it's a lot
more fun it's a lot more impactful a lot
more meaningful and so that's my usual
process now why are people here
i'll prepare a version of my speech to
address those people and then it always
changes up the day of because i met
somebody in the lobby who inspired me or
i met somebody on the airplane the day
before who shifted my thinking a little
bit and gives me an extra story to tell
and when you're so prepared and you know
your stuff so much it's easy to add
those things in
when you don't really know
you're kind of all over the place
so it's being overly prepared and then
the day of being willing to be flexible
it's that like rigidity of practice and
practice and practice and knowing what
you're doing so much that allows you to
play
when you show up it's the
you know going to sports you practice
your free throws so much you practice
your penalty shots so much you practice
you practice so much
that allows you to be a lot more
flexible than play when it comes to game
time let me share another quick example
from the opposite side where i was
interviewing somebody so instead of
being the
person on stage speaking
i'm interviewing somebody and i recently
had tony robbins on the channel and it's
the third time i came on the channel the
first two interviews we did had three
million views on them combined which is
amazing and he's coming back for the
third time talk about his new book
and i'm always nervous before a big
interview
and it's probably the least nervous i've
been because it's the third time on but
i was still nervous going in and so i'm
preparing i'm preparing and preparing
and preparing i'm trying to find a
thread that i care about i don't want to
just ask the same questions everybody
else has asked i don't want to just use
the questions that his pr agency sent
over because
he's going to answer those questions on
every other show i want it to be
different and unique and fun and special
and so
i prepared i know i've got
half an hour with him uh i know he likes
to go long in his story so you don't get
that many questions in so i need to
i need to really be careful of what i'm
gonna say and make this time count
it'd be easy just to show up and ask
okay why did you write this book what
does it mean to you what do you hope
people get from it what was your
favorite part about it and then then
half an hour is done and you haven't
really asked anything super meaningful
so i'm preparing
and
i wrote down on a notepad file that i
had opened when i was talking to him
you know four questions five questions
that i wanted to ask
and i practiced how i would ask them i
practiced you know what what i was going
to say
and then i practiced it so much that
come game time come
showtime here we go tony's coming on
let's let's do our one-on-one
i was able to actually be present and
listen to what it was saying
and and play ball with him right
to throw and catch with him instead of
just going to the questions when you
have them prepared
and you're really insecure you just go
to the questions you just go okay here's
what i said okay here and just ask the
question where the best interviews are
when you can throw and catch right where
they say something and you take that a
little bit deeper
as opposed to just moving on to the next
question because i've watched a lot of
interviews and in the work that i do and
one of the things that i find most
frustrating is
the person says something amazing and
you want them to it's like okay ask a
follow-up question and instead of asking
a follow-up question they just go to the
next question
because
the interviewer it was never even
listening to what the interviewee was
saying they're just so worried about
getting the next question in that that's
that's all they're thinking about and so
like uh-huh okay great and then tell me
about this next question without going
deeper into the conversation so i didn't
want to be that kind of interviewer even
i get it because you're nervous
you're not fully prepared you're worried
about the questions
so one example with tony he was talking
about a recent health scare that he had
and that his career would be over
the doctor said your career is over
and in my head i was thinking about some
of the other stuff i knew about tony
robbins and so i asked him how many
times have you been told that your
career is over
it was off script right it wasn't
something his team prepared it wasn't
something tony's maybe
been asked
i asked how many times have you been
told that your career has been over
because i remember
you know he had this
tumor that made him grow crazy quickly
and and people said his life would be
over i remember he burned out his voice
box and his doctors told him he'd never
speak on stage again and now this injury
that happened to him he wasn't gonna be
able to go and do his event so he's been
told consistently that his career would
be over
and yet he still gets up and he finds a
way and he does it right one of the
things that we love about his ability to
follow through and stay consistent and
so
in the over preparation and knowing his
story and also knowing that i had
questions to fall back on in case
there was a lull in the conversation it
allows the play it allows the freedom it
allows you to adjust the situation which
then creates a much better experience so
whether you're speaking whether you're
interviewing whether you're
coaching whether you're mentoring
whether you're on a sales call
you need to know your script you need to
know what you're going to say you need
to understand your customer and who
you're talking to you need to know all
that and over prepare
but then
understand that the greatest asset that
you have is not in rehearsing again the
script is that you have the ability to
be free now
that you can play because you've done
all the drills
and now you need to have the back and
forth it's it's throwing and catching
i'm gonna throw the ball to you you're
gonna catch it you're gonna throw the
ball back to me it's not just throwing
where a lot of times the biggest mistake
is that you're just throwing you're just
throwing another one and another one and
here's my other line here's my next
question here's my next pitch throw
throw throw throw throw
and the person already saying uh-huh
uh-huh uh-huh but there's no receiving
and them throwing the ball back to you
that's the best part in any interaction
if you have a goal to get them to move
forward to make a change in their life
just to sign you up to hire you to work
with you so you can make that impact
that you're trying to make there has to
be that back and forth and the more
prepared you are the easier it is to
then have the freedom to play just being
honest even when it sucks because let me
tell you how many times it's gonna be
where if you just lied
oh god it would be so much easier and
you would probably get away with it and
but it the way that i explain lying to
people is you get away with it 50 of the
time and so it tempts you to think it's
a good strategy
but the other 50 of the time it is
cratering trust
and once you can't trust the person
all hope is lost
and there's nothing more beautiful than
being in a relationship with somebody
who makes you feel like they're your
number they're number one
and that you totally trust them and lisa
wrote this um instagram post about how
she could see a photo of me with my arm
around a woman or resting my head on a
woman or hugging her or whatever and she
it wouldn't even make her radar to
question it
so
that's the fun for us is having that
level of trust now it's like um i think
it's buffett that said you spend your
entire life building your reputation
only takes five seconds to lose it so
it's like we're so careful we for 18
years we've been earning trust with each
other so like dude so especially when i
was back at quest and
it was
women would come and flirt and hit on me
because they wanted something want to be
sponsored by the company or whatever and
i was around bikini literal bikini
models like all the time
and so if ever there was gonna be a
moment of insecurity for my wife it
would have been that period a she wasn't
insecure and b i the thought of throwing
away 18 years of shared experience of
all that trust and everything it's sex
is like rad and super exciting and i
love it the most but like compared to
what i would have to give up for
something like that it just doesn't rate
on the radar so
and by the way thing something like i'm
saying now which most people would hide
from their spouse oh that yeah of course
i find other people attracted what are
you talking about like we just openly
talk about that like she'll nudge me and
be like oh my god don't you think she's
hot
it's like that's just
we set up early on in the relationship
to be aggressively ourselves and one
thing that we both were really honest
about was i was like look it is human
nature you are going to find other guys
attractive and i will actually trust you
more if you
admit when you find somebody attractive
then if you say something stupid like i
only have eyes for you oh really you're
the only human in all of history to like
uh you know transcend their human nature
like it doesn't make sense yeah and then
that's a super fragile place to be
because what happens if i get older what
happens if i get injured or scarred like
then i'm really supposed to believe that
suddenly you're more attracted to
somebody with a scar than somebody
without like it doesn't make sense so we
all live in this fragile bubble of well
as long as they lie to me it's okay and
as long as i'm willing to believe and
even though secretly i know it's a lie
and then it's the more pious than now
like oh my god she's thinking all these
nice things about me but i'm actually
finding other people attractive and i'm
just lying about it and so then you're
like wait if i'm lying about it is she
lying about it and so it just it erodes
all that trust so from the jump we were
like look you're gonna find other people
attractive i'm going to find other
people attractive but let me introduce
you to this magical word called
commitment
now i'm with you because i love you
because i respect you
but i'm also with you because i'm
committed to you and so you don't have
to worry that i'm going to be looking
over my shoulder for a more attractive
woman there are going to be more
attractive women than you for sure
especially as you age
who the [ __ ] cares
you're my wife
we have shared an experience we've
shared a life we've built this around
each other and commitment means
something to me going back to having
that code that you live by
and the rules and the code that i live
by i'm never going to betray that yeah
so it's like
we've always said i may break up with
you one day because i'm not saying that
like oh there's nothing you could do
that would make me break up with you for
sure there is but i'm never going to
cheat on you
i may come and say i'm breaking up with
you because i'm going to go have sex
with somebody else but i'm absolutely
not going to go have sex with somebody
behind your back never going to happen
so like having that trust and knowing
who the other person is like all that
stuff is is super meaningful and look
there's just more and more and more
stuff but
those are some big ones i'll ask you a
very simple question
why does your organization
exist
we don't need you
clearly there's plenty of competition
clearly people have plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do a reasonably
good job they might even be better than
you in some areas so why do you exist
providing education is table sticks
everybody here does that you can't rely
on that that's why the industry exists
not why your organization exists
that's like when i talk to healthcare
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy like no kidding
thank you
but i know that the culture of one
organization is different than the
culture of another organization
there are cultural norms that wrap
around the sense of purpose cause or
belief
great organizations understand their
just cause a cause so just
that people would be willing to
sacrifice to see the advancement of that
cause sacrifice comes in many forms it
might mean
working longer hours giving you my best
ideas turning down a better job that
offers me more money to stay here
because i believe in what you're doing
and i want to see that advanced
one of my favorite
examples of a just cause
is
the declaration of independence
our founding fathers
declared literally wrote down they
declared why
we needed our own country
all men are created equal
endowed with these unalienable rights
amongst which include life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
they were never against britain
the whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
they won independence there are always
finite games within the infinite game
though they won independence
that didn't mean that they had now
provided all men are equal now the real
heavy lifting began
now let's be crystal clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white protestant men let's be
crystal clear
but even early on during the
revolutionary war
george washington understood how
limiting that was and he realized that
they had to have a broader definition
so he included catholics
he banned any organizing against
catholics and his armies and he would
regularly attend mass to send the right
message some time later
we abolished slavery
and the fourteenth amendment
sometime later we had women suffrage
some time later we had
civil rights act some time later we
implement gay rights and you can see
that we are striving to provide this
thing called all men are equal people
are equal and though we will never
actually get there we will die trying
and the obstacles may always be
different
and what a just cause is
it is a vision of the future that does
not yet exist and you will commit all of
your energies
to advance that vision of the world that
you have
and the people you want to attract both
those who work there those who teach
there and both those who come to learn
there
believe in your vision of the future
so much so
that they may turn down a better offer
from someone else because they want to
be
around people
who are committed to building this world
that does not yet exist and every single
single one of these organizations that
you
run and represent
can have different visions or
overlapping visions of the world but you
must be clear what your just cause is
what you stand for otherwise the only
thing i have to judge you on
is
superficial things
it's like dating right
it's like dating if if somebody tells me
what they stand for who they are they're
talking about their character and those
are the people we want to spend the rest
of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are
what they stand for what their purpose
what their cause what their beliefs are
what their values are
the only thing we have to judge them on
is how much money they make and how good
looking they are you're here today
and
you'd love us a sporty car but
let me guess
you want something that's a little good
on the gas maybe eco-friendly so you can
do your part i got this amazing
two-seater it's fast it's eco-friendly
it's this it's that let's go take a look
at
now that's a sales guy that could make a
job for 27 years and he wants you to
understand him
but what if
you went there that day
because you want you just had your third
child
and you want your wife to have something
that's not a minivan but the big suvs
are too clunky you're just looking for
something in the middle nothing even
close
now that same sales person wants you to
understand him what if there's a sales
person that comes out
and you see him walking over to you and
you're like oh here comes a sales guy
you roll down your window or you get out
and he says hey listen first off i know
it's a saturday we all work on
commissions
authenticity transparency we all work on
commissions it's my turn up i gotta i
get you but i just want to tell you
let me just back up i just want to ask
why are you here today what's your
family like
what uh how can i serve you tell me a
little bit about you
and all of a sudden the person says wow
immediately who do you have rapport with
immediately sales guy number two because
he wanted he wants you to feel
understood and probably not on purpose
that's just who he is all of a sudden
you go well we had our third kid oh my
god i'm on my fourth i get it my wife
hated the minivan when i thought about
bringing it to her house she was like
are you crazy but then i looked at the
monster escalade and she's that's a bus
but we figured out something in between
would you be open to something kind of
in the middle it's kind of like the
sporty uh
smaller suv all of a sudden you're
laughing high-fiving talking about the
names of your kids what's going on in
school that playing softball or baseball
and what they do and all of a sudden
you're sitting in a car going it's a
good guy
and what did he do most the time
he listened
he was authentic one of my greatest
lessons that i learned in starting and
running twitter and starting and running
square
which is how important it is to
instrument
all
usage you have to instrument everything
for the first two years of twitter's
life
we were flying blind we had no idea what
was going on with the network we were
not no idea what was going on with the
system with how people were using it we
were making guesses we were basing
everything on intuition instead of
having a good balance between intuition
and data
and we were going down all the time
because of it because we could not see
what was happening so the first thing i
wrote for square on the server was an
admin dashboard
and we have a very very strong
discipline within the company which is
now 72 people
to log everything
to measure everything
and to test everything
and we treat the dashboard we treat the
analytics we treat the data
as a product
and we call it the inference team
and their job is to instrument all usage
and infer
all action
and that's something that we need
but it's also something that our users
need what does max out really stand for
for you and when did that moment happen
where you knew that that was gonna be
part of your brand yeah um
my son's name's max so that helped um
but maxed out to me means this as you
know um your obsessions become your
possessions whatever you end up being
obsessed with you'll eventually possess
so if you're obsessed with what you're
worried about your fears your problems
you're going to possess those and so
i became obsessed um the the short
version is is that you don't know this i
don't talk about this on camera very
much when i was 30 my uncle died at 50
years old
and he was the guy in my family we all
have this that you kind of resemble or
remind everybody else
my dad's brother he died at 50. sorry no
thank you i appreciate that it's a long
time ago now and um but he was kind of
was my godfather and all my culture
that's a big deal of course might as
well yeah i know shout out uncle mike
yeah mine was uncle mike
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa it's got chills
everywhere right there whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa
whoa
man i thought the universe works right
wow okay
you got me right there
so mine was my uncle mike
wow
and
no man i just touched me
so
mine was my uncle mike and uh that blows
my mind right there brother
so
i'm on i'm at his funeral
we're flying back on the flight there's
this thing in your brain called the
reticular activating system it basically
filters into your awareness what's
important to you that's why like if you
buy a new car all of a sudden you see
that car everywhere on the freeway three
lanes over on the other side boom
another one they were always there why
do you see them now it's filtered into
your importance
and heart attacks were at my he died of
a heart attack
and so i'm on the airplane and i'm
listening to music and on the screens
the oprah show but i'm it's in my
awareness and it's a heart on the screen
i'm like
unplugged my headphones plug it into the
phone system and it was about a new
heart scan that was happening at cedar
side where they could like it's common
now but they could not evasively look at
your heart and your arteries
long story short
i hear it and i told my wife i said
schedule me for one of those exams she's
like it's expensive i don't care
schedule it we call it's a nine month
wait i go i need to get in i need to get
in i keep calling the lady finally she
goes there's a cancellation tomorrow at
two i go i'll be there so i go down for
the scan and thank god this doctor
understood influence and leverage you do
the scan then you come back after lunch
i literally went ate a burrito
came back i wasn't in shape i'm 30 years
old the doctor comes out and he goes um
i'm no i'm looking for edward milot i go
it's my let you know and he goes uh he
knew and he goes
whoa i can't believe these arteries are
in that young body wow you need to come
back son
now my heart's racing i'm like what the
hell's in the skin we sit down instead
of what a normal doctor would do they
just go hey um here's the prescription
take crest store work out eat goodbye he
understood reasons is what changes
people's lives massive reasons not
discipline reasons and habits right
because let me ask you a question your
wife's beautiful
um
do you have kids i go yeah i go i got a
son he's one he goes that's great um do
you want to be there when he graduates
high school
i went what he goes do you want to be
there when he graduates high school i
said uh yeah he goes
okay uh is she pregnant huh i go yeah
what is she having i said a girl you get
to a dad this is what you say he goes
would you like to walk that little girl
down the aisle on her wedding day son
i went what
what is in this scan dude and he goes i
want to be very clear with you young man
i remember this like yesterday because i
want to be very clear with you young man
if you continue down the road you're
going another man is going to live with
your beautiful wife in your mansion walk
your son at graduation and he's going to
be arm in arm with your daughter on her
wedding day not you you'll be long gone
actually as i tell you this right now
dude right
and he goes what i'm going to get you to
do is i'm going to get you to max out
your life and your fitness
and i went
give me it yeah and he gave me exactly
what i needed to do and he said if you
do this you'll walk her down the aisle
blah blah blah from that day
when i get up like i did this morning
and i'm tired and i was late last night
and i don't want to go to the gym i
swear to you brother i swear to you i go
bella's wedding get your ass up and i go
i i'm fit because i have massive reasons
that's why i'm fit and that started the
journey towards maxing out every area of
my life i'm like i can do this in my
fitness i can do this in business i can
do this my spirituality and everything
i'm not going to shortchange myself by
pretty good i'm going to see what my
real potential is what my maximum
capacity is every single day because at
the end of my life when i do die i have
this belief that when i'm done the
lord's going to go well done good and
faithful servant and by the way here's
the man you could have been
this is the man you were born to be this
is the man you were destined to be this
is where you could have gone but you
could have seen the memories you could
have had the people you could have
helped the person you could have become
and meet him my obsession is that every
day i'm chasing that dude so that when i
do die we meet we're identical twins
because the bad end of a life whether it
would be at 30 50 or 150 would be i meet
that guy and we're total strangers so
i'm obsessed with meeting that guy
someday and that's what maxing out means
in that year when i was really broke and
i was really broken i was working at la
unified school district
i was miserable
i was miserable because i wasn't living
in my dream i was just doing a j.o.b
and then one day
i said well what what do i need to do i
i need to i need to buy my freedom
that's what i need to do i need to buy
my freedom well i don't know about
buying my freedom i don't know about
buying i don't know about having money
saved up my family didn't have money
saved up
my mother used to tell me oh this money
is burning my pocket so i know two
things about money it's hot
and we can't keep it long
we'd always have one week where we had
all the food in the refrigerator and
then one week where we were the
refrigerator was empty
right come on come on some of you guys
know about that to this day i spend so
much money on groceries you guys oh my
god it's like i'm feeding like a family
of 10. because i'm so afraid of anybody
ever being at my house and being hungry
and so i i wrote a check to myself
jelani was three
a hundred and ten dollars
i took it to the bank
wells fargo
i started a new account
the next check i wrote
125
and just like the first check i put in
the memo line funding my dream i wasn't
even clear what the dream was
but i knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly there's
something here i'm not even clear about
it i don't know how clear you are but i
wasn't clear about it but i knew there
was a calling on my life greater than
working for l.a unified school district
and no disrespect to l.a unified school
drink it just wasn't my destiny in
today's world we are so busy with social
media and our phones sitting next to us
and facebook and instagram and emails
and text messages that were running
faster than we ever have in our entire
life so when you're so busy it's like we
have a cloud around us and setting goals
just doesn't work for most people in
today's crazy fast-paced world when's
the last time you tried to sit down and
look forward to where you're going to be
in a year or five years it's hard right
it doesn't work anymore so i want to
give you a little hack don't set goals
create a vision for yourself and here's
how you do it let's pretend it's a year
from now and you're looking back on your
year and it was the best financial year
of your entire life you're making the
money you want you have the confidence
you want you have the courage you want
you're living in the house you want you
have the job you want you're treating
your husband your wife your children
your parents the way you want you're
walking around looking younger feeling
better what does that look like to you
write that down as fast as you can write
down a vision for yourself instead of
looking forward you're pretending it's a
year from now you're looking back best
year of your life write it down
that's your vision that becomes the new
way to goals again goals is looking
forward vision is looking backwards the
one you need to live with wake up to
every day is that right there
okay beat the sun up folks you got to
beat the sun up if you can't beat up the
roll up of the senna
you're gonna get beat up in life okay
i've been doing this for a long time now
say beat that thing up that monster out
there that warms this planet that
nourishes
and gives us light the 10x life but you
can't live a 10x life if you're not
beating the sun up
so many of you complain about how much
time you have you don't have time man
because you don't beat the sun up get
started early and when you get started
early that means you need to shut it
down early okay shut it down early so
you get sleep i was i was asleep last
night at nine o'clock
so i could beat the sun up tomorrow this
morning and see
the world wake up with me
if you're not doing block time
here's what your day might look like you
have all these different slots of time
right
and you're just gonna plug in as you go
through the day you're gonna plug in oh
i'll work some there
and i'll work some there and then i'll
try to cram stuff up right at the end of
the day i'll try to cram that sucker in
any crammers crammers crammers cameras
okay just checking no judgment no
judgment you're just not going as fast
as you could
that's all crammers they're i love
crammers
just like because they're easy to get to
move faster because you do have that
diligence of when there's a deadline and
it's on you can go which really serves
you but we got to take you from a
crammer to a preparer to a high
performer and the way that we do that is
to look at this and go
listen
if you keep leaving all these time slots
to randomness
what happens
is they start to get
filled
with the big d
distraction
some
reason it seems like this
hit home for some people
i don't know why
how many recognize what i'm talking
about here
so now
you add up take this out
you might not be thinking too seriously
about it but let's say that's like a day
one two three four five six seven eight
work hours
you didn't know i drew that on purpose
if you leave your time
to randomness you are stealing from your
greatness
if you leave your time to randomness you
are stealing from your greatness bit by
a bit hour by eight hour day by day week
by week month by month quarter by
quarter year by year and decade by
decade and it's the little things like
this where you're like oh my gosh i
didn't get
anything done
because you've got all these random
approaches to your day
and so for those who are like but brenda
i'm a free spirit i'm like oh god i love
free spirits me too
let's go on a yoga retreat
i don't have any time oh free spirit no
time for yoga retreat
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know why free spirit ain't got no
time for real good retreat
because they got no discipline
if they had some discipline free spirit
would have time for some yoga retreat
so if you want more free time you need
more discipline time
it's so simple one of the lines from
right out of the 5am club is
one of the dnas of legendary is
longevity so if you look at the picassos
the jean-michel basquiat you look at the
great sports champions you look at the
great history makers
they were much better at energy
management than time management
and so we're in a war against
distraction right now and what we really
have to do is optimize our energy how do
i do it well i mean i get to the morning
routine which which the whole book is
based on but it's really quite powerful
because if you start your day with
sweaty exercise you're actually going to
activate a pharmacy of mastery that
exists in every human brain i know you
love the neuroscience you're going to
release bdnf which is brain-derived
neurotrophic factor that's going to
actually accelerate your processing it's
actually going to repair brain cells
that have been damaged by stress you're
going to release the neurotransmitter
dopamine which is the the fire
neurotransmitter which we all need as
entrepreneurs and business builders and
and servants of humanity
cortisol the fear hormone is highest in
the morning so exercising first thing in
the morning is going to reduce that i'm
getting into my 20 20 20 formula but i
mention it because it is a way to
maximize your energy
so talk to us about the 20 20 20 i mean
you sort of um started it there with the
the sweaty exercise but what's the rest
of that formula which is pretty powerful
sure so the new book is all about rising
at 5 a.m and that's because if you look
at the great creatives and the great
saints and the great humanitarians and
the great titans of industry many of
them got up at 5am even right now you've
got tim cook and you've got howard
schultz and it goes on and on
before the sun rises is the time of
least distraction before the sun rises
where you can build intimacy and fluency
with what you want to stand for
in your day before the sun rises the
luxury and tranquility of the early
morning hours
you can do that deep inner work
that will allow you to go out in the
world and and play at your best so what
the 20 20 20 formula is is simply this
there's
three pockets the first pocket is move
five to five twenty and you get into the
sweaty exercise because like i mentioned
it releases
neurotransmitters it reduces the
cortisol increases your metabolic rate
which gives you more energy so now and
serotonin as well which gives you joy
so now it's 520 fundamentally you feel
different you have energy your state is
strong you've got a fire in your belly
and you've accelerated your focus
520 to 540 is the second pocket of the
20 20 20 formula which is reflect
we live in a world where a lot of people
are busy being busy but what's the point
of being busy around climbing the wrong
mount everests and so clarity is one of
the dnas of mastery you know this if you
talk to the titans of industry and you
talk to the people really getting
traction around their ambition
these are people who have a monomaniacal
focus on the few things that matter they
have an obsession bordering on a
possession around the few priorities
they want to build their life around and
so 5 20 to 540 the second pocket you
write in a journal
you meditate
you visualize
you do what i call in the book a
blueprint for a beautiful day
or you just sit in solitude and you
think and you ponder and you reflect and
then the final pocket is 5 40 to 6
o'clock and this is the victory hour
the final pocket is grow but if you look
at the greatest billionaires i've
coached many billionaires over the past
20 years if you look at the greatest
producers on the planet these people
have one thing in common they are
ridiculously curious
and no matter how much money they make
and no matter how much impact they have
they maintain a white belt mentality
one of the keys to epic performance
is a relentless commitment to daily
growth so that's the 20 20 20 formula
that the 5 am method is built around and
the premise is basically this as you
begin your day so you hand craft the
rest of your day and if you have
consistently great days you're going to
have consistently great weeks quarters a
year and a lifetime so your days are
your life in miniature and you got to
get those mornings calibrated if you
really want to win no matter how far you
get in life
you have to be able to go back to
scratch in your mind
at a moment's notice
you can never get so far beyond scratch
what that means is
when you accomplish something in life if
you want to go back to scratch
and go back to that seven dollar a month
place where i once lived and visit that
place for a long period of time
if you were here when you went back to
scratch you would now be here
scratch is what makes you better
scratch friction obstacles create growth
there's no friction
when you're this far up in the game
anymore
you think there is
that's right when you change so much the
friction is
is minor
because why
i'm sore i'm gonna get a massage today
i'm hungry i'm gonna eat today the
refrigerator is always full
so your comforts are now so your
discomfort is now very miniscule to your
discomfort back here in the seven dollar
a month place
so you have to go back to the total
discomfort
to then raise your level
of where you're at now i'm not saying
stay there and stay there
visit visit it
and then you raise your level take a day
trip that's right yeah always take day
trips yeah don't stay there that's right
but take a day trip
so when you complete some
massive obstacle and challenge whatever
the adversity that you force upon
yourself because these are all curated
experiences for yourself right you're
scratching constantly
what happens now since this was five
years ago you would just leave you want
to take the medal you would just go on
to the next
what happens now do you take you know a
day to reflect a moment 10 minutes like
how does the process work and then how
do you get back to visiting the seven
dollar
uh you know place you lived in
now i don't have to go back and visit it
i don't have to think about it it lives
with me now
every day of my damn life
that feeling that i had to go back and
think about
i found a way this habit
how did you do it's constantly there i
have a self-talk
i'm a self-talk it's called my cookie
jar
it's a constant reminder of david god
every day of my life
i believe in quiet
there's no growth
outside of quiet
the the world's too noisy
your mind needs quiet for you to find
who you are people what's my purpose why
am i here you're not gonna find it
nowadays unless you lock yourself in a
quiet room in your mind
and find it it's too noisy
for me i could be in a busy street in
new york city
horn's honking and i walk around
with like nothing
it's me and myself in a quiet spot
and
when you are constantly reflecting on
who you are where you've been the
journey you've gone through the journey
you can continue going through
the feeling is always there
you don't allow the world to pull you so
fast
that you forget
you don't allow yourself to pull you so
fast that you forget it's not about
staying in that moment
it's about you want to get to the point
where that feeling
follows you
like breathing
because a part of your life part of your
dna
but it's made like these calluses on my
hands right now they're made yeah they
are now on my brain this is now a part
of me
it's a daily process a part of me and
how i go back to seven dollar month
place
all the time
is now
i go out and i dig fire line i'm a
wildland firefighter i don't need to do
it
i'm a 43 year old man i work with 27
year old kids yeah i'm a rookie every
day i'm a rookie feels like there is one
habit
that i have adopted in the last three
years that has fundamentally changed me
as a business person and it has also
changed my ability to manage my emotions
so i don't get hijacked
i do not allow my phone in the bedroom
i know the research
deloitte just did a study based on phone
use alone and 33 of people are reading
emails in the middle of the night
i know that if you go to bed and the
phone is right next to you right so you
go to bed because you need your phone
you know somebody might need you and you
sleep
you know if this is right here and it's
not closed and the blue light is on
they've done studies where you have
people at a table and the researcher
will put their phone on the table not
even my phone the researcher's phone and
the brain lights up like crazy just with
the presence of a phone the research
around the phone and sleep is so
stunning that if you were to adopt one
radical thing today other than the
five-second rule try putting your phone
outside your bedroom turn off the zip
so you don't hear it tell people who
need to reach you to call you my kids i
have a kid in college a kid who's you
know high school kid in middle school if
there's an emergency call me
there is nothing happening on your phone
at two o'clock in the morning that's
important but if you allow yourself to
become a tool
of this this is supposed to be your tool
for selling your tool for communicating
and we're all becoming the tool here's
the other thing common sense wise that i
want you to understand you wake up
the alarm goes off
what do you do
so you're not even
vertical
and you're reading emails
and what is in these emails other
people's crap so if you don't have
boundaries with this puppy
it's going to impact sleep it's going to
impact how much money you make it's
going to impact how much self-control
you have and so
when i put this thing outside the
bedroom
and i wake up i walk over to where the
phone is it's plugged into my bathroom i
turn it off i don't look at it yet i
give myself five minutes five minutes
before i tune into the world to actually
tune in up here and say what's the one
thing i'm going to get done today
that really matters to me if you're the
kind of person that feels like you don't
have control over your day that your day
gets hijacked that you can't get to the
priorities that you're always behind the
ball this one planning thing will change
your life no phone in the bedroom turn
it off when the alarm goes off five
minutes five lousy minutes
five lousy minutes before you tune in to
the rest of the world
and if you've got the kind of job where
you've got to check it get up 10 minutes
earlier
you have control over this stuff and it
is so important that you take it
seriously now because you're living at
the slowest moment of your entire life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen
in a future video because you are
awesome if you want the seven habits to
beat your procrastination check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i want you to stop
dreaming and i want you to just start
doing small things i want you to go back
to curiosity and less into crushing your
big goals the thing about